à peine sorti du collège elle consulte
d'abord leur blog les étoiles brillaient
encore et toujours mais tu ne m'as
toujours pas remarqué c'est la mode
quand est-ce que tout le monde en a
pratiquement donc tout le monde enfin
presque un ado sur 5 aurait son blog
tout est bon à bloquer un jardin secret
que les parents ne connaissent pas
forcément les parents peuvent le voir
oui mais moi ils sont encore jamais
cette arrière-grand-mère de 79 ans a
très facilement créé son journal en
ligne j'ai été référence et abusivement
par un site pornographique à cause d'une
histoire qui s'appelle La Queue du Chat
et je n'avais jamais pensé dans ma
grandeur naïve que ça pouvait
intéresser un site pornographique
bien sûr des médias qui que l'on connaît
déjà comme la télévision ou la radio et
bien il y avait cette possibilité de
tout à chacun de créer sa propre chaîne
de créer sa propre émission avec
l'internet c'est toujours du possible